Do you have a celebrity crush?
Lots of celebrity crushes.
Who's like the one.
So there's this light skinned
black girl who was in
Saved By The Bell in New Class,
she's still an actress now,
her dad is married
to Beyonce's mom,
so you got to put all
the math together and find her
because I don't even remember
her name,
she's so obscure but she's hot.
What's up everybody,
I'm Chris DiStefano,
AKA Chrissy Hazelnut Spread,
and this is live from the limo,
Stupid Questions,
it is stand up month,
I am with James Davis,
his special airs tonight
it's called Live
From
The Town,
you're going to like it,
you're going to love it,
let's get naked.
What would you say
is your weirdest
recurring nightmare or dream?
I have this dream that
I'm still in college,
and that there is a class
that I just have not been
showing up to,
and it haunts me like,
"Yo you're failing this class,
you just don't go.",
maybe I have unfinished
business or something but-
Well did you graduate college?
Absolutely not.
Yeah well I feel like-
I'm a comedian.
Look at this,
now in the back of the limo,
(bleep)
with hour specials.
Yeah, yeah,
See that?
Yeah take that tuition money.
Listen if you know me,
you know that I like fun facts
so what is a fun fact
about your special
that people need to know?
Show one, not that high,
show two, high off my ass.
Woo, and show two
is what most people
are going to be seeing, right?
It's a mix.
Oh really?
So there's going to shots
where I'm like,
"Oh I'm locked in.",
and then there's a cut away
and it's like,
"Oh look at those eyes."
Does your mom
like your special?
My mom was at my special.
So you don't mind performing
in front of your parents?
Actually no, I don't mind.
You don't mind.
I feel like, they've seen me
at my worst,
they know all my secrets,
there's nothing I can do
to really embarrass myself
in front of them,
because I mean
they cleaned my poop.
My mom has picked me up
from a party
where I was drunk,
you know like-
Is that when she cleaned up
your poop?
Here we go, if your life
was a cocktail,
actually know you know
what let's be honest,
if your life was a type of weed
what would it be,
let's just be real here.
Let's be real here.
Let's be real, what kind
of weed is your life?
A indica dominate hybrid,
goodness gracious
I hate how specific that is.
Listen you're having a problem
and America knows.
Now a strand,
I would just say Green
Crack, I just like the name
Green Crack.
Green Crack!
Heres the thing green,
I'm making money,
crack,
that's like my jokes,
they're addictive,
they have you coming back,
"I need more of that James
stand up comedy.",
I don't know ...
you don't put the crack.
No you don't.
I think not, but we've already
established weed is my drug,
now that is something
I don't want my mom to see.
That was Stupid Questions limo
edition stand up month edition,
it's kind of like a new kind
of deal that we have this month,
you still get
a stupid gift, okay?
Okay.
Now it's January,
we're in New York,
you're from L.A.,
you like hats, so I thought,
"Why not get you a New York
a hat that does look
like the colors
of a certain New York team,
but it is not, we just bought it
as a 99 cents store.",
and it's for you and I know
you're swagged out,
so that I figured
is the hat for you.
It reminds me of the beanies
that Eddie Murphy and Arsenio
Hall were wearing in
Coming To America
when they got to New York.
There you go, now you've got
something new
to masturbate into, perfect.
Genius.